I thought your whole take on the
homeless situation when Seth Seth Green
I think his name was was yesterday well
we got a housing problem it's not
housing problems right now we get right
right now they all have housing that's
right and they're go walking let's see
go to Venice that's going I know there's
some in Woodland Hills do these are all
brutally ill and they have to put them
into treatment and into housing they
will not go on their own and they're you
know to be fair Newsom's rhetoric
shifted with this crisis and he's begun
to talk about mental illness and
services and treatment he's just not
doing it
well Newsom was part of that whole thing
about there was this weird very strange
left-wing sort of wall against calling
this an addiction imagine how they were
to blame the economy rich yes and how
housing it was a house insurance and it
was almost as strange this strange thing
that they were all they knew the
difference so they are so blinded by
their ideology I went to the White House
again Newsom is disappointing he's had a
stuffed shirt with his [ __ ] height in
his hair I don't like it
I'm giving him a good grade for what's
going on right now
all right but but he I went to the White
House gave a talk about how this
happened how we destroyed the mental
health salon America and where they all
got belched out onto the streets and the
prisons and the nursing homes that's it
we may know that that happened that was
a Supreme Court decision and I think it
doesn't it pretty complicated did a lot
of gay pictures when he was in the White
House that's not a joke that's so was
that we at the White House three or four
months ago and how was it very
interesting it's really fascinating how
so well first of all everyone around
Trump there's some he is some amazing
smart people around I loved meeting the
people in the West weighing in the way
and they're all they are just about what
can we do to make life better in America
that's it what do you think we should do
what do you think what do you think well
there are some ideas we're just trying
to make things better it's a these
they're super enthusiastic and did you
feel those ideas
I spent yeah I spent the whole day with
these all right with the secretaries are
and secretary Carson and I just I fell
in love with those two guys oh wow
they're amazed and Carson ben Carson
mazing that all be with the physician
right
yes neurosurgeon there you have the
letter
dude it pains himself in this house
whatever and he's been hehe is really
working on the the homeless thing he is
coming he will he till all this went
down he was on his way to really take
care of what do you think should happen
with the homeless you here is it's a
series of things need happen they need
to change the laws around mental health
and you need to have some ability to put
people on treatment than the treatment
we went overnight in the in the early
70s from the criteria for treatment was
the doctor decided that person needed
care to harm to self or other that's a
giant distance there's a lot in between
yes so we said we need to have the
ability you mean physicians literally
yes ok what happens the Supreme Court
decision was essentially and correct me
if I'm wrong it was the idea that the
state unless you are a danger to others
and yourself the state has no right to
take you and force you any in the tree
to end it so a new made a point of
saying if schizophrenic is rolling his
own stool in a ball down the road that's
his possession and technically a police
officer you can't touch and touch it but
if it's but do you want to but if it's a
demented patient with the same symptoms
and you don't intervene you're guilty of
abuse yeah what what the hell yes sir
musicians certain brain diseases or
privilege and certain brain diseases or
yeah may have to get treatment you have
to put them somewhere to somebody people
though get caught up in the idea of how
do you define mental illness that's a
huge one right so somebody could have
depression sometimes in their mentally
ill right if if you if your illness has
driven you to the street
that's a terrible sign right that when
you've lost everything you've lost your
job you lost your ability to function
functionality is the defining feature of
mental illness can you function are you
in distress you live in a car you how
are you is your current adjust course
harming you oh come on can we help them
drill oh my god yes and and with the
other thing I'm killing this no I'm just
idea okay let's not talk still our
spreading code personal storming idea
the skits are dining the schizophrenia
if you intervene early you can change
the course of the illness they can yes
dementia is progressive no matter what
yet that's the one we intervene think
how effed up that is that's so effed up
well what about nicotine escrito for
what nicotine for dementia I read a
study that it make sense to me anything
that causes alertness but should do that
Oh crazy Mike sent me all the creatine
stuff so I think we're eating every day
me to take nicotine to doctors we've
talked about I would if needed because
I'm on this sort of carnivore s diet I
haven't needed an appetite suppressant
my weight has been what is another thing
I was not talking about it
I brought him the bad boys from Sweden
the bolts I really threw it but he's big
concern what is this gonna do to my
teeth forum it's very interesting I
think you thinking I might want to do
that diabetes drug yeah yeah Toby's drug
buddies dollar a day and they found that
most met forum patients don't get cancer
right it is it has some sort of and and
it's a lunch one drug that is associate
with longevity too i I've done that I've
done it keeps the glucose levels
yeah it must have something else it must
be so yeah like we just don't know
apparently it makes it essentially like
it be like keeping your glucose levels
low so that even if you eat certain
things be like being on keto all the
time where you're not you're not feeding
anything sugar I heard a lot of actors
take it I don't there's there's a big
push for metformin in the anti-aging yep
and I've done some research I'm too much
of a dummy to fully understand it but
what I found though I and this applies
you it can dramatically
negatively impact performance oh for
sure
so they're like warming up some boxes
[ __ ] gas I'll be shredded wouldn't
[ __ ] my high kicks up but well I'd be
leaner
probably because I don't know I think
it's stimulate your appetite can i [ __ ]
yeah I mean you ever know anybody take
that one like I was gonna say any
minutes could do that too but let me go
back to my furfrou yes I I feel like so
we all we need a directive to physicians
that were there we're required to fill
out whenever somebody gets a major meds
illness diagnosis okay so it just like
we do with it with aging we go when your
brain isn't working right and you're on
a ventilator or you get dementia or you
have an ADD you know pneumonia and
you're unconscious I want you to
destruct me what to do so you have
schizophrenia and when you decompensate
what you will let's write down now
exactly what I should do to help you so
I can have the with the right to get you
off the street and make you better yes
and families are begging for this we've
been up to Sacramento multiple times
begging them for help they have doctors
and resources and money in a home F off
their still get out of here who do you
think you are because it's because it's
it's violates their ideology would you
think do you think your children don't
have agency or said it like do you think
the brains don't get sick brains get
really sick and agencies affected I mean
measurable evidence don't we we're a
fact how much more measurable evidence
you need somebody who has who lives in a
cardboard box and rolling their [ __ ]
right and okay but I said honestly I
really think first off a lot of those
people and I just know this from like
kind of bumping elbows with them in the
recovery community and also living in
Venice a lot of those people don't have
any support network they never had
anyone Horseman in their life they were
they came out of the womb [ __ ] where
their their their their you a drug
addict drug it apparent many mentally
ill parents maybe no parents and with
pre-existing mental health problems
you're [ __ ]
yeah you know I a lot of times I'll look
at dudes walking down the street like
asking for money to buy a beer at 7 a.m.
and I and I get overwhelmed by the
feeling like man pretty much the only
thing that separates you from me was a
zip code we grew up yeah is that my
daddy could wipe my ass every time I
[ __ ] up you know what more or
sometimes I think some people you know I
have theory on that like when you see
somebody who smokes weed all day long or
they drink called I think a lot of
people are born with a very low level of
say serotonin or whatever it might
really be self-medicate old me ever like
my father's best friend was he was named
I was named after he never felt good
somebody's over unless he was drunk and
that that started happening when he was
13 years old
and that's just his wiring and I'm just
lucky that I was born with a certain
amount of genetics where I don't need
that I'm just [ __ ] lucky I see a
wretch on the street sometimes and I
just go he didn't choose that he didn't
[ __ ] choose you I did anything doctor
no no no never but what mike has a very
pointing but as very doctorly you calm
down thank you well he has a very
powerful statement about his
relationship with substances I I think I
know what you're referring to is like I
this is you know this is hard to say
sometimes but I have a child and a wife
who I love more than I could possibly
imagine sure more than I can put into
words I'm not sure I can't confidently
say that I love them more than I love
methamphetamine that's the nature of
addiction which is why their families
their job don't their why their lives
can fall by the wayside and literally
I've had patients say to me I could I go
no I'm out it's gonna kill myself but I
couldn't do that to my drugs I loved
them so so good
this is fascinating it isn't so good
it's only so good for people like me I
can't do this to my drug so generally
tambour you know the actor so he was
he's a great actor and he was trying to
play he had to play an addict and he
couldn't figure out it's not an
addictive personality and he couldn't
figure out like how to connect to it
right so he he spoke to an addict and
the addict goes I don't know how to
really describe he goes well can you
give me something because he said I mean
I guess I guess you know sometimes when
I would I when I would think about it
like sometimes I would come I got it
what that was real it was cocaine yeah
yeah we'll do that that's right he said
that was the drugs stimulant it's like
that one teen mom is it Macy's baby
daddy who's just a drug addict and
there's a scene in Teen Mom where like
where you see everything through the
prism of team-high now it's ridiculous
but he's driving his hi oh he's driving
his lady mama
and he's fall asleep in our do
they're filming this there's a GoPro
knees I can see the ends I didn't say
getting back to what we're talking like
the worst data getting back to what we
were talking about earlier you know
where you start like in your mind all of
you are probably I'm not maybe not him
but here's thinking how on earth could
you drive with your child [ __ ] up I
can't sit here and judge the guy I drove
intoxicated every day not with the kids
or no and but I have my phytic aid at 19
absolutely I be happy hi I'd be hi
behind in front of the with AB so thank
you you know this is where you where
compassion has to play and and not
taking credit for your like I always try
to remember not to take credit for the
fact that I'm somewhat successful and
I'm not kidding and yes and beautiful
but it's alright but in other words it's
well it's just I was given I was made
lucky luck but but what do we do with
that a lot of it's luck a lot of it's
luck but a lot of it is hard work and
everything and Alan like bother you also
coming here for the last seven years
every Monday Wednesday late and get my
back hurt and show what you still come
but I got seven years right but again I
was raised with that work ethic with
that idea where we're no wow huge flaws
drop like it went entertainment show
sabotage I know yeah I had a hard time
you've got so you had self sabotage for
a long time but you as always but I was
always at the same time I was always I
had these I had a stable enough life and
upbringing and mentality born with that
where I was always able to accomplish
things right still you know what I'm
saying like I leave [ __ ] hit the how far
do we go with this you didn't get
neuroblastoma when you were to you know
I mean I didn't know I mean yes getting
through life is in a course a crazy
navigation it's amazing we get one day
than the eggs but you know you maybe
people just don't have the machinery and
maybe that's what I'm saying yeah but
just should you then feel bad for no no
it brings up a larger question which is
the question of free will that's all I'm
saying and that will complicate yeah
there's a there's an argument and I'm
looking at our grow a tablet from broad
science view it's like there's a little
bit of it's like a nice little goulash
there's some there's some nature and
there's some rockin
nurture and his pleasure God we're
directly with your career like dude
we've talked about it you-you-you gave
one podcast a shot didn't work out you
didn't [ __ ] throw in the towel you
have another one shot you gave away you
met this guy then well it's yoga hey
let's give it a shot knee and then
the--since knees actually no the caption
kept showing up and you'd like a Joan
Rivers said on on Lois show I'll never
forget it man she did there was an
episode of Louie back when he was still
allowed to make content where I was
special okay that's pure fire and Joan
Rivers was again he had just done a
terrible show at like some casino and he
went up to Joan Rivers room and she says
you know sometimes the music's gonna
stop in your career you just gotta keep
dancing yes and it's like the people
like me that just it doesn't matter
house [ __ ] good you just gotta get
stopped for a while for her yeah
stop yeah and while for her who did she
pee no one would answer her phone calls
and you know so but it's true in a lot
of areas of life though right things can
turn down turn up you you just you keep
working you work hard you hope you do
the right thing it's a little bit like
you know your life is gonna have doubts
we know this it's exactly like we are
going to be faced with black swans it's
gonna be one that's right you're the
black is this is the black swan your
knees blush it's gonna happen where
you're gonna be like can you believe
this shit's happening can you believe
that I am thrown into cast at my 401 K
or whatever it might be or I don't know
where I'm gonna go next right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]